una revolución es un cambio una
transformación profunda del pasado
inmediato que va rompiendo los
paradigmas y los conceptos preconcebidos
hasta ese momento la historia de la
humanidad se ha visto fuertemente
condicionadas por los modos de
producción indudablemente pero así como
esto es evidente es innegable vincular
también ciertos temas como la innovación
y el desarrollo tecnológico para
condicionar los lineamientos que ha
seguido la humanidad
en 2016 el profesor klaus schwab
fundador del foro económico mundial
acuñó por primera vez el concepto de la
cuarta revolución industrial o industria
4.0 todas las revoluciones anteriores
que hemos vivido nos han dejado cambios
sustanciales en la humanidad la primera
por ejemplo empezó transformando las
sociedades agrarias y rurales en
industriales y urbanas y su icono es la
máquina de vapor la siguiente revolución
nos dejó la bombilla y el transporte
esta fue la revolución del motor de
combustión interna y la producción en
masa la tercera revolución que es
justamente la que estamos despidiendo es
la era digital la que nos dejó el
internet la computación las redes
sociales las tics
según el profesor schwab esta cuarta
revolución industrial incluye todos
estos sistemas hay ver físicos que
incluyen la robótica el internet de las
cosas la nanotecnología y la
biotecnología y muchas otras cosas más y
es aquí donde quiero ser muy categórica
diciendo que él
tiene un papel protagónico en esta
cuarta revolución industrial como
podríamos nosotros ser protagonistas de
esta revolución industrial siendo el
país más megadiverso del mundo estamos
empezando a vivir una nueva revolución
industrial y esta es la revolución de la
vida
la biomímesis o la emulación de la vida
es una estrategia que nos ha permitido
dar solución a ciertos problemas de la
humanidad basándonos o inspirándonos en
la naturaleza y más allá de querer
superarla su sabiduría lo único que
hemos podido hacer es imitarlo
el 'tren bala' es uno de los iconos de
la ingeniería lo llamaron de este modo
porque su punta simulaba la punta de una
bala y al igual que ésta cuando cambiaba
de presión y de ambiente emitía una onda
muy muy fuerte que era un producía un
sonido ensordecedor el tren bala tenía
que pasar por un montón de túneles ella
y la cat sur que además de ser uno de
los ingenieros que participó en el
diseño del tren bala era un audito logo
aficionado encontró la solución a este
problema en la punta del pico del martín
pescador el martín pescador logra entrar
a muy alta velocidad en agua y ni
siquiera salpica y no perturbe el medio
de los peces
la flor de loto una belleza inigualable
crece y se desarrolla en el lodo como
hace la flor de loto para no permitir
que ningún microorganismo ningún polvo
se acumule en su superficie tanto de
pétalos y de hojas no se debe a que la
flor de loto produce cierto químico o
cierto metabolito vista de cerca la
superficie de la flor de loto tiene una
compleja estructura de protuberancias
que forman una capa hidrofóbica y no
sólo no permite la acumulación de polvo
y de microorganismos sino que al recibir
el agua de rocío y de la lluvia éste
corre libremente y logra eliminar
cualquier resto que pudiese haber
quedado
todos los que usan una compañía europea
ha desarrollado una nueva e innovadora
pintura de características hidrofóbicas
simulando justamente las protuberancias
de la flor de loto para exteriores
impide que el smoke se acumule y ahorra
millones de limpieza
por otro lado existe una nueva corriente
de soluciones basadas en la naturaleza
que abarcan muchísimos enfoques
integrales para utilizar los ecosistemas
y los servicios que estos proveen para
dar soluciones a los problemas más
comunes de la humanidad
los mangles son plantas extraordinarias
en las costas en todas las comunidades
costeras siempre ha habido el problema
de las inundaciones
y siempre se ha utilizado estructuras de
hormigón que a la larga terminan
colapsando no solo por la resistencia
sino también porque generan muchos
pasivos ambientales y hay que invertir
mucho más dinero en remediar los por el
contrario los mangles pueden regular el
nivel del agua y además crea un
ecosistema muy amigable para camarones
por ejemplo que pueden ser explotados
incluso económicamente
nos enfocamos tanto en dar soluciones a
problemas que siempre han existido
existido soluciones nuevas por ejemplo
las plantas de tratamiento de aguas
residuales complejos sistemas de
ingeniería que utilizan criterios
físicos químicos y biológicos además de
un importante componente mecánico
después de todo el diseño ingenieril
éstas terminan siendo más o menos
eficientes sin embargo un humedal con
las plantas adecuadas puede absorber así
incluso metales pesados y crea un
ecosistema amigable para aves reptiles y
anfibios las soluciones basadas en la
naturaleza buscan aumentar la
resiliencia de las comunidades
utilizando los servicios que ya tenemos
finalmente dentro de esta revolución de
la vida un pilar fundamental es la
diversidad microbiológica
tenemos una compleja relación entre
todas las especies que habitamos en el
mundo y generalmente la diversidad
microbiológica suele pasar desapercibida
enfermedades como la sífilis la
tuberculosis la gonorrea la difteria son
causadas por bacterias y así como éstas
nos predisponen a sufrir ciertos
síntomas también hay otras que de no
estar presentes no podríamos generar
serotonina por ejemplo es decir que no
estamos bacterias para generar parte de
la felicidad que tenemos es tan compleja
la relación humano microbioma que
tenemos más o menos 40 millones de
células humanas en nuestros cuerpos y
unas 30 millones de células bacterianas
en general se estima que en el planeta
existe al menos 1 millón de
microorganismos es decir 10 elevado a la
54a organismos y de estos conocemos el
0.001 por ciento imaginen cuánto
potencial tenemos en el país más
megadiverso del mundo cuantos
microorganismos ya de por sí están
solucionando ciertos problemas lo vemos
en los derrames de petróleo son los
microrganismos los que ayudan a remediar
los por sí solo esa compleja estructura
de los ecosistemas que permite
regenerarse continuamente y los
microorganismos tienen un papel
protagónico
ahora imaginen si nosotros nos fijáramos
con más detenimiento a todo el mundo que
nos rodea quizás podríamos encontrar
muchas soluciones a los problemas y que
son evidentes
'nunca es un proyecto ecuatoriano que
utiliza una cepa de microalgas
ecuatorianas las microalgas son famosas
porque son responsables de generar más
del 50% del oxígeno que respiramos en el
planeta no son los bosques son las
microalgas y tienen una increíble
capacidad de absorber co2
'nunca ha simulado un sistema acuífero
que potencializa las capacidades de las
microalgas para realizar fotosíntesis y
con esto absorber muchas toneladas de
co2 de hecho un solo dispositivo puede
absorber más de 100 veces co2 que un
solo árbol ocupa un poco espacio y
pueden ser mimetizados en la ciudad
porque son estéticamente agradables
asimismo como
tenemos estas soluciones innovadoras
para dar solución a problemas urbanos
podemos aplicarlo al campo con una
colega desarrollamos un sistema para
salvar las orquídeas
el ecuador es el país con mayor cantidad
de orquídeas en el mundo las orquídeas
son las plantas vasculares más complejas
y evolucionadas porque su increíble
capacidad de imitación morfológica miren
esta orquídea tiene un insecto ahí
encima tantos millones de años para
desarrollar esa habilidad el problema de
las orquídeas es que más del 80% de
ellas están en alguna categoría de
extinción y esto se debe porque sus
semillas no pueden germinar por sí solas
porque justamente se reconocen a sí
mismas como un engranaje nada más en un
sistema complejo de interacciones
naturales y necesitan la interacción de
un hongo simbionte que le provea de
carbono nutrientes y humedad lo que
hicimos fue desarrollar un pequeño micro
encapsulado que junto a las semillas de
orquídeas y este hongo simbionte y puede
ser depositado en cualquier parte y
garantiza que estas semillas van a
germinar el problema es tan grave que de
un millón de semillas que nos depositan
en el suelo y los bosques sólo una
llegará a ser una planta adulta
y somos el país de las horquillas cómo
es posible que dejemos perder esta
biodiversidad con estas
microencapsulados podríamos reforestar
bosques enteros
relativamente fácil
ahora quiero llamar a la reflexión y en
realidad estamos tan afanados en crear
cosas nuevas en creer ser hijos de
nuestros propios méritos que hemos
olvidado que no somos la cúspide de una
pirámide de especies sino que al igual
que las semillas de las orquídeas y los
hongos que interactúan somos un simple
engranaje en un complejo sistema de
interacciones naturales y esto va más
allá del concepto proambiente o
ecologista este vínculo natural nos ha
sesgado y los he quitado la capacidad de
ver las soluciones que son tan evidentes
y que están ahí para nosotros si bien
las tres revoluciones industriales que
hemos vivido con anterioridad nos han
ayudado a desarrollar nuestras
capacidades y aprobarlos a nosotros
mismos como especies han terminado
dividiendo a nuestra especie como tal y
generando daños casi irremediable de
nuestro planeta
este es el momento preciso para crear la
revolución de la vida este es el momento
preciso en el que todas las revoluciones
que hemos pasado pueden ser
reivindicadas porque solo necesitamos
recordar de dónde venimos y hasta dónde
queremos ir gracias
[Aplausos]